ladies and gentlemen Siege fans far and
wide prepare yourselves the Lord of
leans the peaking Prodigy sieges chosen
sun is Calling it Quits bolo the
YouTuber turned world champion is
retiring from professional Rainbow Six
Siege I know a lot of you got questions
and thanks to the lovely lad himself I
got answers I was given a chance to sit
down with the boy before his
announcement went public and get the
full story
so let's get into it
[Music]
so yeah for those who don't know J Ane
bolo Doty is basically the most famous
Siege player alive and if you ask me and
tons of others he's also the best he
started uploading insane kill montages
onto YouTube back in 2016 and before
long became a certifiable institution of
leans flicks and all-around impossibly
talented orchestrations revered and
replicated by 15 year olds the world
over by 2019 at the tender age of 18 he
entered the big leagues and became one
of the only content creators in Esports
to not only transition into professional
play but Transit I think TSM might
overextend uh through office and out of
nowhere bolo's just in the site this
might work out for TSM this Mexican will
take down two there but it's right out
from bolo now he's down to the 3v3 in
the post plan scenario another one runs
heading down but Paulie will get one
Bola with three on the round now looking
for more coming closer and closer to
Jaws music to amplifies but now in the
hallway that's four for Bolo
but I'm not gonna recount the whole
story because
well I already did that way back when he
first got his start it's sort of a
well-known video feel free to check it
out over the past three and a half years
he has led TSM to three back-to-back top
three slash four finishes at the six
Invitational including a win in 2022 so
why is it that he's deciding to call it
quits
well there's a few reasons but a big one
by his own admission is that win in
February of 2022 we all got to watch as
bolo's dreams came true and it was then
apparently that he first started
contemplating the prospect of retirement
what else is there really to do you know
other than just go for repeats and
everything I had a bad stage following
up at 2022 and you know that's when it
really even hit me too like like you
know maybe I should just you know call
it quits but that kind of got shut down
um you know I I kept playing and
everything but
after sl2022 is one like the first
thoughts started happening
and then you know I'd say probably about
maybe a month and a half ago it kind of
resurfaced and like more serious than it
ever had been because like after SI 2022
it was more of like a you know do I
really want this you know my performance
is down maybe this is just an easy way
out but now it's like this seems like
the right choice regardless of course it
wasn't until this Invitational which by
the way he was going to retire after
whether or not he won qualified Etc that
he decided to actually pull the trigger
and a lot of you may be wondering
why is he simply following the age-old
adage to quit while one is ahead well no
the reasons are a bit more complex than
that the biggest of which shouldn't come
as much of a surprise unfortunately put
simply Siege Esports ain't doing so hot
and for a creator of bolo's stature
it's just not a super worthwhile time
investment anymore just didn't make
sense for me
and I don't think I could have lasted
another year because you know SI is like
the time to to hang it up you know
that's the end of the year and you know
for for everyone involved in the scene
you know your team the org that's like
when decisions need to be made and
that was just you know the the time that
I think was the best time for my exit
regardless of performance because
obviously you know I would have liked to
have ended
qualifying for SI defending the title
whether we do good or not you know at
least just being there
but it didn't work out that way failed
to fill the qual you know lost lost the
grand finals of the quals but I think
that didn't really
counteract my my decision just because
it it needs to happen just for like a
brand thing you know
I just don't think it's really worth it
for me at the moment and I know that's a
really sad thing to say out loud but you
gotta remember Volo did the thing he
lifted sledge's Hammer IRL and once you
do that even just once
what else is there and again it was just
kind of like a you know I fulfilled my
dream
because you know younger I would always
go watch SI I would see people with the
hammer SI 2020 was my first event I had
to see the team that beat me lift the
hammer you know in the in the stadium
and then I finally got to do it and it's
just like because that's all that's all
it was about you know playing good for
the year to play good at SI and then
it's like what's what's beyond that you
know it's not necessarily like
complacency I didn't have complacency it
was just kind of like a you know is it
the right choice for me to continue and
once you factor in the overall health of
the Esports
it kind of seems like a no-brainer
player numbers viewership whatever it
may be but I think it's still like
salvageable like it's still able to be
kind of you know
not saved but
enough to
you know keep it some more healthier
than it has been
but I don't know if I can say that about
the Esports scene
because it's just like you know you look
at the major like Grand Final views and
everything it's just it's not it's not
what it was not what it was and I think
I would rather just go and pursue more
to like the content like the community
of seed right because even even what you
were saying was like I went from high
school to Pro like but even like during
High School I was never full time
content like I was still going to high
school I would still scrim and then I
would do you know rank YouTube and
streaming so like this is gonna be the
first time where I'm actually just like
you know I wake up all I need to focus
on is my brand my community you know the
people that have built me up and that's
the end of my day so
you know I'm I'm excited to kind of just
fully commit to one thing instead of you
know dipping my toes in a you know this
bucket this bucket this bucket so now
it's just you know all all one goal here
so yeah bolo is returning to content
creation full time which is great will
it be sad to not see him compete anymore
of course but as he reiterated to me
that SI win really did change everything
for him because it's not about the money
you know I I am you know not
hard to imagine but I'm the highest paid
Siege player
you know in in professional play
by a good margin
and it definitely isn't about the money
just because like
like if it was about the money I would
have stopped a long time ago and just
focused on content creation just because
that's you know if that's where the
money is brand deals
content creation all that stuff is where
the the big dollars were made
and I stuck with the game you know the
Esports scene and I've taken a hit on my
content for a while and sacrificed
opportunities you know I'm not losing
money but sacrifice the opportunity to
make more money but it was definitely
about the Love of the Game love of the
Esports and just the the actual
competitiveness of the scene
but again just one SI the scene isn't in
that good of a spot and now I'm kind of
at like a Crossroads it's like do I want
to keep sacrificing my brand my
community that you know built me up and
got me to this insane level that I'm at
right now or do I keep kind of I guess
staying with the sinking ship that is
the competitive world of Siege and again
I don't want it to die I don't want it
to crumble you know I'm sure this isn't
the best decision for Esports health for
Siege you know if I were to hang it up
but it's just something that kind of
needs to happen bolo has always been
very open about how indebted he feels to
the community of so-called believers who
turned him into what he is today career
Ambitions aside returning to content
creation full time will allow him to not
only nurture and grow that Community but
reward it the month leading up to me
being announced as a pro player my
content my community Wars now in a
better word just kind of neglect it
because I had to prioritize things to
you know Propel my pro career
and it's just it again it just it took a
hit I didn't feel good about it my my
streaming hours were inconsistent my
uploads were inconsistent it just wasn't
that good like I I wasn't you know
paying it back to the people that really
kind of
helped me rise throughout my youth
basically and so yeah the future I think
is right now just gonna be dreaming just
like
like a consistent stream schedule you
know I'm gonna be
explain more seed than I have been like
realistically I'd probably be playing
more seeds like more than my competitive
um my competitive career like on a
day-to-day basis just because it's like
it's all about content now I don't have
to worry about you know 100 performance
at all times I don't have to worry about
all the you know nuances of competitive
play I can just focus be myself hang out
you know and actually kind of have fun
right it's like now it's instead of a
performance it's about fun it's about
enjoying your time what this also means
is that the boy is staying with Siege
Rainbow Six will continue to be his
bread and butter both from a casual and
competitive standpoint I want to commit
more to content you know just do more
and I think this way I can kind of go
back like I've already got like the
competitive Community behind me for
Prestige content and I still want to
keep that so I also have like some
competitive roots in mind you know I'll
have you know certain stuff catered to
that but at the same time it's like I
want to go back into the cat casual side
of things you know just just like that
oh this guy's crazy got a you know a 4K
with tachanka one tapping people or
whatever it may be like stuff like that
you know gotta I gotta hit up the tick
tock you know that that crazy stuff
um but of course at the end of the day
like
I I'm not gonna it's not gonna just be
like the same thing like it's not gonna
be like Bo still on TSM and you just
booting up a stream but it's just longer
like I want it to be different I want it
to be more you know like an actual
content piece rather than just you know
some Pro Player booting up his dream
and I do want to Branch out on games
that said he can and will try new things
which is super exciting just don't ask
him to run valorante
not his Jam as it turns out I tried the
Val thing valve's fun and all maybe I'll
give it another shot after after
everything's you know in full motion but
recently I was I was kind of like I
approached like do I want to play Val
it's like a second game or CS as a
second game I played val nope I played
CS I missed this
so I think I'm gonna try to play a
little bit of Cs you know again maybe
some foul maybe some Tarka or whatever
but I think I definitely want to play
another competitive shooter and
obviously tarkov's not that but I want
to play another competitive shooter you
have in my Arsenal in the event that
Siege doesn't last my man now you may be
wondering is this on the Esports
retirement or a real one like is he
gonna come back in three months or is he
done for good I too was curious
so I asked him right now I don't
anticipate coming back I don't
necessarily want to
um but like at least a year maybe if
somebody you know like uh I don't know
like people do it sometimes like maybe
like somebody needs a sub for an event
or just like some small thing maybe
maybe because like at the end of the day
like I don't really I want this to be my
exit like this I want it to be this
but of course
with everything said about like the
reasons why I retire like if Siege you
know makes a rebound and it goes back to
its thriving game that it once was and
Esports is healthy everything's healthy
and it's the right decision and of
course it just depends on where I am
content-wise where I am you know
mentally do I think it's going to be a
good decision Maybe
that's that's it's a big big maybe but
again I think this is my exit I don't
plan on coming back but you know the
future has not been written yet so we'll
see so for all intents and purposes
bolo's professional Siege career has
come to a close
what a career it was you know I've had
such a good storyline like you you have
to admit like it's been a really good
storyline and you know
the the rank star turned up to go pro
turned up to win S.I obviously I've only
won one SI I've won I haven't won a
major I've won a minor you know Regional
stuff like the little mini Majors during
covid
and
good SI placements and then finally an
SLI wins this one hits home for me
I had the privilege and it is a
privilege of sort of chronicling each
and every step of Bo's competitive come
up he is a lovely human being an
extraordinary competitor and his story
is one of the greatest I've ever had the
honor of telling so to see him hang it
up is it's emotional I and many others
consider bolo to be the most
individually talented player ever to
touch Siege he is by no means the goat
in terms of accolades but in terms of
raw unadulterated skill he is a special
singular Talent here's the thing though
those who know bolo will tell you that
he is absurdly
impossibly humble like to the point that
it's almost infuriating so when I asked
him straight up humility be damned where
he ranked himself in terms of pound for
pound individual greatness
I was sort of surprised at his response
like if you put me up against people and
I I feel like I've proved it like when
you when you P when you have the people
that you talk about individually just
individually not like you know igl
versus what it's just individual players
and if I'm feeling good I'm feeling
confident and I'm at a good event you
know I've got a good support system
around me yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna win
against everybody right like it's just
like it's happened like again the people
that you talk about like Shaco paulu uh
Nest like
there's good battles there's there's
videos of you know our our legendary you
know engagements and everything and in
my mind yeah I'm I mean you know credit
to them they're sick but I'm sicker I
cannot believe that I got him to say
that on camera like I agree with him you
just you have no idea how unlike him it
is to gas himself up like that you can't
really think about bolo without thinking
like R6 Esports and you know even even
on my end like forever cemented into my
history and my memories and it's played
a huge part in just my life literally my
life it was I was anticipating 2018
going pro for years I finally got there
and it was an absolute blast winning
events you know eventually winning SI
and doing good at basically every SI it
was it was phenomenal and I am extremely
extremely grateful for everybody that's
been involved you know teams or
management you know media producers and
YouTube channels that have helped but I
just I just think it's really time for a
different a different path and I just
think the
overalls way things have played out for
the game for the Esports scene and just
overall all of PC gaming honestly I
think it just it just points to this
direction where I just need to you know
step aside let let other people do their
thing in the Esports side and I need to
go back to content creation and just
focus more on the community side of
things because I think that's where the
Legacy really will stay alive so it's
been a good three and a half years and
I'm you know I'm really looking forward
to the next couple years as a full-time
content creator and I'm excited to see
where it goes hopefully I don't be
coming you know a washed up old man
anyway that's pretty much it I think I
speak for the entire Community bow when
I say
thank you for being Na's chosen one for
getting us another hammer for everything
I am extremely excited to see you back
on the content grind
and I can't wait to see what you do next
he's 21 years old he's 21 years old and
all he talks about in the interview he's
like yeah I need like a secondary game I
mean like in case like Siege like you
know goes under tomorrow right he's like
I need like so he's like so I started
playing Valor and I was like nah he's
like I started like CS again he's like
oh I missed this God damn dude CSS
I was like here we go dude